welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
at twitch.tv for slash h3h3 productions
every tuesday and
friday
uh it's just my lonely ass here
cut to the wide shot
and now you can just see really
how sad it is huh
but the good news is ela is on a plane
right now coming back
man i'm such a lonely [ __ ] guy dude
christ
look at cut to that white shot again
i saw a post on the subreddit it's like
it's like the whole gang is here
i always count on our fans to make me uh
feel good no but anyway it's been fun
and as always thank you all for spending
your tuesday afternoon here with us
means a lot
appreciate you
letting me in to your life and touch you
in that special place that only uncle
bobby ever touched you
he shouldn't have touched you there
shame on him
today's podcast is sponsored by seat
geek
and
raid
world war ii a new video game by my
friends over at starbreeze it's out
today
on steam
more about that later and of course
h3h3shop.com
support us directly there and of course
viewers like you
who subscribed to us on twitch using
twitch prime or just a straight up
subscription by the way half off this
month
so tip of the beanie
yeah i'm so excited ela is coming back
ah man i know i really underestimated
how dependent
i am on her it's kind of [ __ ] up
like
when i was living by myself before
i don't remember being such a pathetic
[ __ ] loser
but i guess you just get dependent on
somebody after
so much time but i don't know it's been
a tough it's been a tough couple weeks
like
we well clearly the reason she's there
is sad
but we just moved into a new house like
two days before she left
there's just been so much to do
we didn't have like a studio set up in
our house so i wasn't able to work
it's just been
a
i've been masturbating with my tears i'm
not gonna lie
i had a lot of time to masturbate
specifically with my tears a slick tiny
little vibrating
tube you guys really love that sound
bite out there
um our advertisers love us by the way
um anyway yeah i'm super excited for her
to be back this friday she's back just
in time because i need to emphasize that
this friday the
red carpet celebrities the bradbury
boroughs i'm ethan bradberry i'm talking
mo
i'm talking des ethan
are gonna be in here this friday
um i'm so excited like honestly probably
if i could choose one guest it would be
them
we just have so much history together
with these guys it's like
i mean one of our first big reaction
videos was pranks in the hood which was
heavily focused on them
you know you got spike it's like they've
been around it's like our our destinies
are intertwined
it's like a great literature right it's
like um
it's the hero's journey
or something like that it's joseph
campbell
he'll be jealous
if only i'll tell you stranger life is
stranger than fiction nobody can write
it this good
anyway
i made a thread on the subreddit that i
would love
for you guys i saw a lot of people
saying like hey i've got questions for
the bradbury boys and so i want to base
i mean it's helpful for me just to like
hear what you guys are thinking and so
if you guys have some interesting
questions you could throw them in this
thread here
goddamn it you could throw it in this
thread here and um we'll look over it
before we go live with the bradbury boy
so i'm going to spam it in the comments
here so if you have any questions it's
there on the subreddit you'll see it
even if you don't know don't like just
go there
um cool i'm i'm super excited about that
sorry
i think i was too close to the mic on
that one
fishbowl we spoke about fishbowl the uh
spiritual predecessor of shark tank it's
like shark tank but less money less
experience less interesting to watch
fish bowl
are you excited
um there's like so much
basically for those who don't know i'm
like i was obsessed with shark tank and
i love the idea of having our own little
shitty version of it here
and so i want to have people come pitch
their business ideas to us
and the winner gets like a 50 000
investment from us
so
there's like a lot of legality so we've
been talking with our attorney
we have to like draft some kind of
consent form and make a website and
think of like rules because it's a
contestant there's all the kinds of laws
and [ __ ] around that so we didn't forget
i'm super excited to do it just gotta
cross our t's
and dot them eyes
um brian john smith and skippy bringing
those guys out soon i haven't forgot
about those wonderful angels
um
god i'm so proud of skippy you know
a guy raised three thousand dollars with
his belly button apparently he
undervalued it at 2500.
so when you're gonna be uh smoking that
is that coming up to you uh
i don't know i got some cold feet i was
planning
justin roilan and alex well just it was
justin's idea he's like let's smoke a
blunt of skippy's belly button lint
if we hit 200 000 but he and we crossed
200 000 on the charity but he's like oh
only today
it was i only met today
week i'm like dude we raised 235 and
you're telling me you're not gonna blaze
that [ __ ]
hit that [ __ ] for freedom dog take a
kneel before or i don't know what are
you supposed to kneel or not i'm not the
whole nfl thing
i think if those all go those guys could
just get a blunt of skippy's belly
button let there be peace on earth
that nfl [ __ ] is great i'm not i'm not
i'm not going to comment on it by the
way
it's just crazy to see how charged up
everyone's getting i'm not i'm not
i'm not even gonna touch that [ __ ]
that's one of those things
which is sad i feel like there's [ __ ] i
can't even talk about because
people get so angry by just expressing
your opinion
about something these days it's it's mad
people are so upset like on both sides
about this nfl thing take a neal
you salute the flag
careful getting too deep anyway i'm not
even going to touch it and more i'm more
like interested in the fact that i can't
touch it
that it's that like people are so
freaking divided it's like such a team
politics man
well i'm not gonna touch it i'm not
gonna take debate this time folks i'm
just gonna have a sip of this ice cold
coca-cola zero not a sponsor
yet
it should be
should be because i'm gonna start
i might get a test taste for pepsi max
coke
it's on you
um oh and later we have almir
of overkill coming in to talk about
anyway we'll get to all that let's
[ __ ] get right into some [ __ ]
now y'all know that i love sucking elon
musk's dick
and as we touched on previously his dick
actually expands and contracts he has a
cybernetic [ __ ]
so maybe some girls like it like a chode
some like it like a noodle
elon can accommodate all of your needs
because his dick is like um
it's like a balloon
you fill it up with more schmutz and it
gets fatter i've heard this through the
grapevine he's very satisfying sexually
um anyway
so he was dropping bombs on twitter bro
um usa today here let me show you this
picture i love this
this is why i love elon all right
usa today tweets out mercedes makes a
one billion dollar bet it can take down
tesla
it's like this whole big thing mercedes
apparently all a lot of the car
companies volkswagen are hurt are
investing a ton of money into electric
vehicles
and i think it's smart i mean it's
clearly
whether you believe in global warming or
not it's clearly just like a better way
to fuel a vehicle right it's like
it seems like the future so everyone's
putting down money on that
and um elon responds that's not a lot of
money for a giant like mercedes wish
they do more off by a zero
love it
but so here's the great part
next day they tweet out this
damn lear i guess these guys own
mercedes you're absolutely right elon
musk here's the missing zero investing
10 billion
in next generation evs and 1 billion in
batteries
got him he just says good
can you believe this [ __ ] guy
you know what i don't suck his dick
enough i don't give him enough credit
tesla recently they they made all their
patents public
like they released all of their
technology publicly to anyone who wants
to use it because they're trying to
generate
the ev market
i i mean i i get the reasons why i think
you it's like a
they've made the best progress in
converting our existing infrastructure
to you know accommodate electric
vehicles but it's a huge undertaking and
they need help to do it
i think he's smart in knowing that
competition in this area is is only
going to help them because they need
charging stations
they need infrastructure
you know like this [ __ ] costs money man
it's incredible what they've achieved
just with the tesla
you can drive from l.a to new york now
and charge all along the way
not stop at a gas station once god bless
them the guy's dick it goes from one
inch diameter to 12 inches i mean it
goes all the way up to 12. i don't know
anyone that would need that but i'm just
saying options available
that's what a great guy is
all right so that's my daily elon musk
dick sucking
now here's actually the story
the the main story that was really
interesting to me this twitch streamer
reckful
was he's an irl streamer on uh
on twitch
what are the chances of this [ __ ] man it
absolutely blew my mind
dude is in my parents are in spain right
now in barcelona for my dad's birthday
and their anniversary
there's my mom you can see her right
there
these guys are out in barcelona
irl streaming and my parents walk
through the back
and the chat explodes like that's
ethan's parents the guys don't recognize
them
and they just keep meandering through
the back of the camera
and then they end up it's it's just so
bizarre it's just what are the chances
let me show you this [ __ ] that's true
a
[Music]
you said sure like it wasn't really
right no no yeah okay
by the way there's conspiracy theories
that exist that these guys
these guys knew
there's some compelling evidence but i
don't i don't see why that's true but
the way that their framework is so crazy
it's hard to believe that when i say
barcelonian yeah sure okay but i think
it is but anyway this guy's like staring
at him right
a little [ __ ] interesting i don't
know why they would set it up but you
said sure like it so anyway here's my
parents just like framed up perfectly i
thought you had to believe it
ten thousand people watching all that to
get grills or something no you only need
you just need this thing
yeah
that's it exactly my dad [ __ ]
haggling with this guy
trying to save two dollars or some [ __ ]
off like a 10 purchase
he's he's negotiating for a good long
time too i'm glad you can't hear what
he's saying i'd be embarrassed
but it's hilarious they're literally
negotiating with this guy for like 20
minutes
anyway the chat is like exploding let me
let me fast forward i don't think they
speak gabriel
what do i say
i say are you h3h3s parents no but they
didn't hear you
okay
yeah i'll wait for them to buy the
lights let's wait
oh wait wait until they buy the lights
guys
wait how about wait i'm just filming
it's turning in circles and you guys see
h3 for these parents like what small
world man chad do they speak
five minutes later he's got one dollar
off that price man he's killing it
all
right
all right i'll speak english right after
this
oops
english
i i mean if i say h3a
i actually haven't seen this whole thing
let's see i'm just like those are
totally israeli names
let's go
check demonstration
ethan's parents
they're still picking lights yeah
they're still picking lights that's how
i feel all right i know my dad too long
boys
[Music]
get in there boy
[Music]
be rude
man this is not
[Music]
this guy for so long close the deal man
let's go [ __ ] well this is like a whole
long courting ceremony okay here we go
i'm also i'm a twitch streamer he
streams on twitch now right so i know i
knew him yeah that's really cool
my my viewers are back hey i'm sorry to
bother you are you ethan's parents by
jesus you are
i'm also i'm a twitch streamer he
streams on twitch now right so i know i
knew him yeah that's really cool
my my viewers were all seeing they saw
you in the background of my video and
were spamming the chat yeah this [ __ ] is
so [ __ ] weird what are the damage
same time
by the way
oh really oh is that for me i feel bad
now i was making fun of my surprise
dude what the hell i was making fun of
my dad and he's over there buying my ass
a gift i actually like those lights
they're pretty cool i hope it is for me
and i hope you got at least two dollars
off the purchase price the asking price
or i'll refuse it
oh does he speak hebrew
he's supposed to
i love it they try to give me more
credit than i deserve
no in short i do not speak english
either of you speaking
i read it okay
anyway um what the hell dude such a
small world dude was super nice to my
parents though very wholesome experience
so shout out to reckful for
setting up that whole weird and wild
journey with my parents
what else
oh god man i fell into this rabbit hole
you guys ever heard of wendy williams
this [ __ ]
is bizarre
weird and wild stuff
i'm getting really deep into like um
daytime talk shows the dr phil's the
oprah's the wendy williams i'm just i
don't know i find the whole thing
fascinating
absolutely and and wendy in particular
is is um
is the gold cup winner for conf like
just what
um
she's like oh my god just let just watch
this story like this is my intro to her
old son yes his name is kevin jr okay uh
what kind of mom are you i'm just
thinking like wendy williams the mom i'm
trying to imagine you at home
let me show you something else first
so this lady has a show like oprah
and she's got this insane audience when
she walks out they have they have like
rituals it's like a cult like a bunch of
screeching housewives
and when they when she walks up they'll
go
like like a long time like for five
minutes and she comes out and she goes
oh
oh you
like that's her thing that's her slogan
i haven't seen um
i haven't seen a slogan like that since
jeff dunham's i kill you
they both kill
i need a slogan
and just i don't know if you what don't
you have a few
i don't i need something that i do like
every time i'm on camera like ooh fupa
oh i know one fascinating okay
all right
i need to dress that up a little bit
but i don't know the whole thing is just
so bizarre um let me let me intro you
guys to the world of it's actually
really inspiring to me because i've been
i'm really trying to put together a show
treatment
and i'm thinking of of like what would
my dream show be like
and
i find these daytime talk shows really
inspirational just because
it's weird and wild stuff
and it's a great format you can talk
about anything you can talk about videos
current events
and it's just it lends itself to some
absolute spoofs i mean here take a look
at wendy's my biggest inspiration right
now
i may need to get breast implants and a
ton of plastic surgery my goal is to not
be able to show expression in my face
i don't really need to say anything
honestly i don't need to say anything i
don't know it's just the whole thing is
so it's surreal it's like an alien
universe
just look at her face i mean that's an
emoji right there
oh yeah yay
[Applause]
there it is oh i i don't know it was
with this guy this weird [ __ ]
youtuber basically re-uploaded
her clip but just
he him
doing little bits look at this
that's it
that's all he edited it was him doing
that
[Applause]
this is the show they just [ __ ] love
her ass
anyway
um i'm i'm absolutely fascinated by
wendy williams i don't know i don't
she's she this show is um
this is like the third most popular talk
show in the whole world the whole planet
she's a superstar
just like the meme theme disser on
twitter if you guys remember him
oh yo oh blue
[ __ ] is bananas man
look at this intro it's like it it it's
as if
editor is doing a meme on them
it's way it's so high energy that it's
like bouncing and exploding
laughs
gets to me it's just
everything's high energy except for her
she's not capable of expressing her
energy in her face
just all these people chanting her name
and she's just like staring back she's
very stoic about
she's very stoked about all the love
that's that's thrown on her which is
part of what's so bizarre about it her
whole thing is just like yeah i'm windy
i know you love my ass oh you
i don't i'm not trying to like hate on
her she's achieved a lot she's she's
she's
clearly she's a strong independent woman
and a very hot pink dress
it's very hot pink it's hard to look at
it hurts my eyes i'll be honest
i'm surprised her producers let her put
that on
but i the whole ecosystem i was like
going through this rabbit hole yesterday
night and my draw my job was just on the
floor
um
i mean that that that this stuff is so
popular i'm like completely out of touch
i'm so into the youtube world
i don't have cable i think that's part
of my problem i need to get cable so i
can actually know what's out there
um look at this there's a there's a how
you doing compilation
wait
i saved this how you doing
compilation
this was [ __ ]
powerful stuff
here's seven minutes of this triangle
[Music]
i guess it's supposed to be absurd
it's one of those things like poe's law
where she just does it for so long that
when i watch her come out on stage and
drop out how you don't win how you doing
it just seems real is that like a
friends reference
are we going that far back for their um
no no she specifically has said that
it's not an italian how you doing it's
uh something completely different in
fact dan it's nice that you asked me
that because i have this video queued up
to explain the origin of this so
this incidentally is not it
um
this is not planned i'm just this i'm in
this deep
here we don't plan anything
wait what the flip let me watch the dang
video for you accidentally america
i know that some of you are wondering
what is how you doing how are you doing
reading of the wendy williams
mess you don't say it like joey tribiani
from france there you go no she just she
directly answered your question
dude what the [ __ ] these guys put a
giant annotation over the video you see
this [ __ ] this is so infuriating
if you try to click it deposit it takes
you to the youtube channel how are you
doing wendy how you doing get the [ __ ]
out with this [ __ ]
it's triggering
i'm not doing good wendy because you put
an annotation over the whole video
dim your eyes like this
and when you get to the end of doing you
spread your bottom lip i'll do it once
and then go to my website dan take note
of this
i want to see your best how you doing
you understand
hold on let me let me get my notepad
okay all right i'm gonna go back
you watch this [ __ ] now get to the end
of doing you spread your bottom lip i'll
do it once and then go to my website and
you can take lessons okay look
how you do it
they love it
she did it i can't believe she did it
i'm gonna try it honey
i feel like she didn't do anything to me
she doesn't deserve to be made fun of
i'm just an [ __ ] i'm a cynical piece
of [ __ ] i find people who are happy and
having fun and not causing harm in the
world and i [ __ ] ruin it
that being said
how you doing
something like that how was that
that's like a four out of ten
well it's my first time
oh that's true
not bad but anyway like sh basically
wendy williams is my inspiration for for
whatever show we we're cooking up i love
it i love the daytime tv [ __ ] i love the
um the squealing
housewives and the free
the fetish sizing of like putting free
cars or whatever like free
there's this one clip of tyra banks i'll
never forget of her like
she i swear to god she passed out like
um
like like uh vaseline
just vaseline and everybody's you have
to watch this to believe it tyra banks
vaseline look at this [ __ ] it's unreal
she lose her damn mind because she gave
everyone a little tub of vaseline
reveal my biggest beauty secret ever
tyrique tyra actually fascinates me too
i need to do some research on tyra her
show with straight bananas it's my eye
and anything cream meaning i and
anything
all right and during the break we had
some really hunky boys that brought out
these very special boxes to our studio
audience and inside the boxes is my
super duper no fell skin saving eye and
anything cream
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm getting so caught up
[Music]
they're acting as if this is like an
oprah car giveaway but they've literally
look at the [ __ ] joy
what's in the box it's a tub of vaseline
i [ __ ] you not it's
like how much could that cost
they're act this is
like
look at look at this
exuberation
this has to be a parody right nope it's
tyrant
you get the cream it's like listen i
know oprah did this she actually gave
away cars that's exciting you're it's a
tub of vaseline
but it's just this this thing of like i
got something for free
i want to do
i want to do like um
i don't know if i should be talking
about my show ideas publicly but
whatever
there's a c there's like a hypothetical
c this is all copyrighted
don't steal this [ __ ] all right
i want to do like um the under the seat
gag
but it's just like garbage like actual
garbage and then and then like um
the janitor comes through with a plastic
bag and everyone throws it in the bag
is that funny
like a ice cream wrapper look under your
seat
the janitor will be around please
please help us clean up the studio from
last week's performance
just like a gag every time but i just
look at this [ __ ]
you get a tub of vaseline and you get a
tub a mini tub of vaseline we couldn't
shell out for the big ones these are the
travel sizes
[Music]
[Applause]
tyra you're worth like a hundred million
dollars you just gave away like a
thousand dollars worth of [ __ ] look at
her she's losing her [ __ ] mind look
at her
look at this
are you guys seeing this [ __ ] she's
rolling around on the ground like she
just found god
[Applause]
tyro
i think the crowd is getting concerned
at this point
[Applause]
[Music]
wait still even still she says it's
worth a hundred dollars
so there's like a hundred people in
there so what like ten thousand dollars
worth
tyra tyra shits ten thousand dollars
just a hundred bucks
oh it's not even money it's a tub of
vaseline that doesn't have reach sale
value
you know
it's not easy to resell a tub of
vaseline
partially used
only dunked in once
only applied to my dry
itchy [ __ ] once
i double dipped full disclaimer
outcomes your wildest dreams your
wildest dreams
how has this not has this been parodied
i feel like nobody's parodied this stuff
before
has someone else done this i feel like
it's relatively original i
i
want to believe that this is a parody i
promise it's tyra banks dude
i'm not [ __ ] with you dude this is
real
this isn't a parody tyra banks is not a
comedian she she has go just to google
and type tyra banks it's in lunacy after
lunacy
look i'll show you another one of her
she does this like uh fake out she lies
like a host on a reality show um
that just i mean she's she's man here
watch this watch this and tell me if you
think that
that was
[Music]
what's the hardest part of being in this
competition not knowing what's gonna
happen next really well you guys are
this is like top model or something so
you've gotten this far
so is it is it hard walking into the
judging room
i've been working so hard i'm so tired
you guys
so
i'm so sorry you guys i don't mean to be
all weak in front of you but i'm just so
lightheaded
somebody bring some water
[Music]
super concerned about her
[Music]
acting
wasn't that so such a sane thing to do
they're like why did you fake that like
that's not acting
you just [ __ ] up honestly yeah
like we were worried about you
she's she's pretty nutty no that [ __ ]
was real
so anyway that's kind of like my dream
right now is
we're thinking about this whole wendy
williams tyra banks thing
um a little dr phil a little jerry
springer
sprinkle some joey salad on there
and you got yourself some ranch and hey
you got yourself a show am i wrong
all right let's um
let's thank our sponsor today today we
thank the glorious
glorious people over at seat geek
seatgeek is an app
that aggregates tickets to live events
from all over the web to make buying
simple
that was bad timing nice yeah
like the call of cola
i don't control it
but that clearly not a reflection on sea
geek that was i just want to make a
disclaimer
the burp was not
that's not on the sheet no it's not on
the sheet and it wasn't like a it wasn't
an editorial
decision either
um
see
seatgeek is an app that aggregates
tickets to live events all over the web
to make buying simple they put a 0 to
100 score on each ticket to let you know
if you're getting a good deal or a bad
one green equals good and red equals bad
in the app you can view seats
so you can see where you're going to sit
if you go to seatgeek.com
or use the link in the description
enter code h3h3 and you'll get 20 off
your first order
click the link in description to
is download it's actually a great
innovation and and buying tickets online
i love what they're doing with the
rating of the seat
because they do it on a scale of zero to
100 but you get the view from the seat
so if you're like looking for a dodger
game or kendrick lamar concert or
whatever you you choose your seat you
get the price and then you get a view
from the seat and you get to see where
like how far you are from the stage and
how good your seat is if there's a beam
right in front of you you know you
didn't have that technology i went to a
dodger game once with my family i was
literally in front of a [ __ ] beam i'm
wondering how the [ __ ] do you sell a
ticket with a beam in front of it well
apparently they do and now we have the
technology so that you don't get stuck
with the beam unless you want it there
because i was scared of foul balls when
i was a kid i'm not gonna lie my dad
used to take me to dodger games all the
time and i was terrified of foul balls
because he my dad the lunatic that he is
he was obsessed with catching foul balls
so he would sit us and like um
he would sit us in foul foul ball
territory
he would specifically buy those seats
and i says dad i'm afraid i'm scared i'm
a child there's projectile
rockets raining down
from the sky towards me like several
times every game at least
i'm not i can't even enjoy the game i'm
just paranoid all the time he says shut
up he slaps me in the face
he didn't do that
but i was scared my dad is such a
lunatic he actually got two balls two
foul balls
pride out of the hands he's that dude
who pries the ball out of the kid's
hands in the video he's like one of
those guys luckily luckily we were going
to to games before youtube existed
anyway
with seekgeek you could prevent all that
so use the code h3h3 if you're in the
market for
hitting up
at an event a concert whatever you like
head on over to see geek and use code h
to ensure you get 20 bucks off
so support the show thank you to seeking
and now
we have with us almir from starbreeze
who is the i guess the marketing
director over there he's the one who set
up i don't know if you guys heard about
the dlc for payday 2.
um
payday two
god such a huge game it's been it's
still like elmer was showing me right
now it's like still like the number five
or six most played game right now on
steam after like five years or four
years
and they're making a dlc where they're
putting me and ela in the freaking game
and basically giving all of the
the proceeds to us
it was super nice it was like a
unbelievable generous thing i'm super
excited we almer you want to come in
here
um
what up have a seat
so i was just talking about um the
payday dlc yeah
um
we would we we uh i underestimated how
many lines are in that game
yeah you did everyone does everyone does
first of all you know thanks for having
me by the way oh yeah of course thanks
for coming hello internet
um
the payday
there's like a ton of custom voice lines
in that and they're like yeah like we
put you in the game we record your voice
it's like a whole cool thing that we're
and
um
i expected to go in a couple of times
for like the voice acting we must have
gone there like we must have spent like
20 hours in there yeah and the craziest
part
was like um
you you have to shout and say all this
crazy [ __ ] and ela cannot raise her
voice yeah because it's a bank robbery
game right so you gotta yell you know
get the [ __ ] down right now get up right
chase is in a pickle you know these kind
of things yeah cool the one that we
always said the first one went there was
just like scream as loud as you count
downstairs
that's someone that we always joke about
yeah
you just have to scream everything
because it's in a gunfight yeah yeah and
so after the first time it was like i
can't do it i just i simply can't do it
but why because she her voice was tired
or just because she felt incapable she
couldn't get into the character she
couldn't scream she couldn't raise her
voice yeah and so she's like just tell
him just you do it i can't do it
and like there and then you guys were
really nice you're like no just give it
a shot yeah you're trying i mean i work
with a couple of different actors right
and everyone you know have a different
you know challenge you know becoming a
bank robber so and becoming a career
criminal but
ela i mean dude by the way where the
hell are you
and secondly you know complain she's on
a plane oh yeah
ella's on a plane that sounds like a new
height
good for you dude that she's coming home
i know it is good for me trust me yeah
but i was so surprised by positively
surprised by i mean her her acting game
it's crazy
yeah she scared the
[ __ ] out of me dude she went from like
i'm just telling no i can't do it to
being like all right i'm terrified like
her voice acting skills i've never heard
a shout and you have some examples right
yeah we do yeah let's hear or do i have
it you have them you have him yeah we
shared the drive with you yeah so we
have some sneak peek stuff for you
pediahysters out there all right so hold
on one sec let me open this up yeah
don't worry um
so that's coming later in the fall yeah
our goal is to to get it out the door as
soon as we're done right so we've
recorded uh we recorded all the lines
with you guys more or less we might you
know do another recording just to catch
up the straggling lines you know if we
have some new content that we need to
match up or whatever
and then of course you know it's about
finishing up the characters i think we
we have some some images that you might
chat so this is me in the game
damn that is insane
the fupa's and we're we're looking
forward to hearing people's feedback
because this is the first time we show
it in public so this is obviously a work
in progress
you can see the fupa you can see the i
love how the suit
the white gloves yeah
well i i'm not sure what color they're
going to be in the end what kind of
glove color would you like
because they're usually blue you're a
white little guy yeah okay
classy classic and i get a i get a tight
little suit like a magician like one of
those old school magicians with the
white gloves right right yeah i make
sure that all the pressure is on this
one button
for any heister tuning in so i flew in
just for this call for this did you
realize yeah i just flew in from sweden
all the way from sweden uh 10-hour
flight here
just for the these moments to get with
you ethan and afterwards i'm flying
straight to zagreb to meet up with the
lion game lion the developers of raid
yeah oh wow that's going to be cool
you're flying where do zygote being
creature yeah jesus man yeah it's a lot
of flying it's a lot of flying yet right
i think i got it's good stuff so here we
go oh that's terrifying yeah it's a bit
terminator-esque it doesn't when you
when you match them up like that
so here's ela yeah she looks she looks
like a real hit man ela is gonna be the
star of this game yeah i'm here just as
a little sideshow yeah this is going to
be crazy and
you know paired with the voice acting i
mean she's going to be incredible
dude your guys are incredible though
yeah there are so many yeah the p the
patty crew is fantastic i mean the
developers are doing such a such a heck
of a job yeah i look like such a [ __ ]
idiot
that's me though you guys took pictures
you rendered my body this is me we put
some white gloves on it and we agreed on
how you were gonna look and then we have
the perk dick that we've been talking
about so the idea of the perk deck is
that we wanna
uh we wanna we want we want a perk deck
that is uh is built around you guys
helping out each other oh right yeah
yeah yeah so and we had the document and
people will be able to see it in the
past but or going forward but uh
we this is obviously work in progress
tough uh the goal is to to find you know
uh a cool setup but yeah we'll see it
was actually cool when we were in sweden
we met and we're like well let's let's
figure this out together
and i do you guys have something like
this in the game where it's like a two
character
me marino where you no this is the only
character pack where you get two
characters for the price of one
essentially yeah and we we said that we
were gonna stop doing dlcs and we're
gonna uh this is the final one and like
we said during starstream earlier in the
year when we agreed on doing this
because this all started like a like a
goof right yeah totally yeah
it was april fool's total goof yeah and
then people were like we need to see
ethan and heal in the game
and first you know people were like
ethan and then you know people were like
gila you know and yeah initially we were
like yeah of course you know it's so
natural when you think of it that both
of you have to be in the game
i'm so happy to hear both of you wanted
to well i'm just excited because i think
the characters are actually fun to play
yeah it's not just a marino there's
gonna be some spoofs and a couple of
booths in there as well of course listen
to this [ __ ] i mean i haven't heard
these by the way
oh my god
yeah i haven't heard any of these yeah
it's great yo that was [ __ ] insane
they're like okay
god it was rough man i was like okay
can you you'd always be like can you
just turn it up a little bit i'm like
dude i'm dying yeah turn it up again
shout out to another knockout
he's fantastic well done oscar
taking both of these guys
shrek and you're in my swamp oh my god
i don't even remember because i did so
many of these hey control i've been
thinking are you into boy bands should
we start a boy band what do you think
there must be like thousands of these
lines seriously just pretend this is
relax hour and i'm not here grab
yourself a juice box and shut the [ __ ]
up
get down [ __ ] yeah now we're
talking
you're starting to sound like a real
criminal i'm telling you dude i'm
meaning talk or i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
jesus
all right now now to the real part yeah
it's [ __ ] payday guys
take him down
that's great that's good
i love the intensity yeah it's just
straight up good
hey control um i had this strange dream
last night i was some kind of a youtube
star it's it was weird pretty cringy
i left the cringy part
cringy that's that's awesome
i want to go shoot some bradburys after
we get off work
get down now
i just can't wait to hear
all of her lines yeah just shut the [ __ ]
up and lie still
it's just i love it [ __ ] talk now and
imagine you know with the intensity of
the music you know the ambience in the
game cops all the gunfire and so on and
you hear these voices i mean yeah it's
to be completely it's kind of exciting
it's it's it's sick it's dope you get to
hear ela scream yeah it's crazy for for
hours essentially
and then next up well you guys just
released a new game today yeah which is
like the spiritual successor to payday
2. correct
world war ii yeah raid world war ii you
want to talk about that a little bit
yeah i happened to so uh
raid world war ii is essentially a
spiritual successor to payday mm-hmm
the creative director of the game ilia
petosic and his brother used to be a
part of the overkill crew working on
pedi and ilia is actually one of the
co-founders of overkill so he's like the
original gangster
and he's one of the designers behind
payday the franchise itself right and uh
when we were successful with payday 2
we decided to to help him and his
brother create their own studio
in zagreb in croatia because they had
this idea this dream of theirs that they
wanted to create move back to their home
country because they grew up in sweden
after the war
in in the balkans in the 90s and they
had this dream that they wanted to move
back to zagreb and create a
a game studio and we we loved the idea
and they pitched raid to uh us in the
payday group and we were like
we're like we love this these guys know
how to make a fun game they do i mean
clearly these are guys who made payday 2
which has been like one of the most
successful games ever yeah i mean ilya
uh the creative director for raid world
war ii he was the lead level designer on
both peter the heist and pd2
yeah he's behind you know no mercy you
know a lot a ton of the different heists
for people
it's exciting to get
because the thing is like i feel like i
came too late to the payday scene yeah
yeah it's fun it's still happening dude
five years in we're still getting on the
ground level of the game that's what i
always like about like mmos so now you
have a chance to like get in
from the beginning yeah and it's so
great you know for us to see it go live
today you know what a feeling you know
and especially for the developers down
creation how long have you guys been
working on it a couple of years now yeah
so it's been a long time coming right
but you know the feeling you know we're
so excited to see people jump in and to
see the changes we've done from the beta
because during the beta we got a lot of
feedback a lot of critique regarding
some systems in the game and the you
know the great thing about lion game
lion and and and you know the actual you
know spiritual spiritual successor part
of it really you know other than it
being a co-op multiplayer game you know
that is shares the same kind of
intensity and adrenaline that payday
does is that you know these guys will
listen you know just like you guys
listen to your community the lion game
lion will listen to theirs you know and
being a part of it from the get-go from
the beginning with a new ip i mean this
is a this is a brand new game and a
brand new game design
from these developers exciting yeah and
you know they want to hear the feedback
so so there's a lot of changes so
definitely check out complaints
everybody yeah send the complaints
because we're going to listen and we're
going to communicate and talk
let's see here's a trailer check it out
[Music]
[Music]
it's a good old nazi killing rob
it is yeah it's set during the world the
second world war obviously and uh it's
it's set in a time when you know the
axis powers were still winning right so
you know
yeah so so you know it uh
the allies are having a hard time and
they rescue
this
uh
band of prisoners of war
from the gestapo and the british
intelligence tells them that if you seek
redemption we have an opportunity for
you so if you want your freedom you have
to join us and fight the axis and and
and you know
make life hard for you know we're saying
it's like inglorious bastards plus
suicide squad yeah you could say that
yeah and it's inspired by a ton of other
things as well yeah so imagine you know
everything that we've learned
from developing payday and and making it
into the co-op
heist or shooter fest it is and taking
another shot at it you know through
another game and start starting fresh
yeah so really excited to see all the
people starting playing you know and
people jumping on board and today it's
the pc
raiders who get to start and in a few
weeks time in october uh it's going to
be available on xbox one and playstation
4. play between pc and xbox oh i don't
think we're going to focus on getting
crossplay in there uh i always found
crossplay weird yeah because i
i i think you know any
any way you can get more people to play
together is a great thing uh so if we
can if it's a simple solution and it's
easily uh implemented then we'll
definitely you know prioritize it but i
think you know with there's so many
other things for us to do right now in
the start of the post launch campaign so
yeah we're excited about it cool yeah
crossplay has always been such a weird
thing i don't get it how can someone on
xbox play with somebody on pc it's like
completely different it seems that the
pc player
would have like ultimate advantage no in
what sense you mean would they have an
advantage
yeah you should see some of the console
players i mean they're unbelievable with
the hand control they think the things
people can do yeah i guess yeah but it
just seems like a mouse yeah way more
the great thing about the raid world war
ii is that it's a co-op game so it's the
players versus the environment so you
don't really have to worry about you
know if someone is better than it's just
like uh yeah everyone's on the same team
yeah kind of thing yeah yeah exactly
yeah so it's like you know like a 18
kind of thing yeah yeah so it's a it's a
it's a it's a mix between like an action
game and a satirical like it has a
satirical comedic side to it as well got
it yeah and we did some cool live action
stuff i think we're gonna have a look at
that now john cleese apparently uh who's
also in payday too yeah is now we were
joking my colleague yeah now that we've
done so
we're basically friends yeah we're cool
yeah yeah you're best buds for sure you
said he's gonna do lines about us and
payday too oh yeah absolutely yeah
we're colleagues yeah so any gila
kleiners out there have any any lines
you'd like
john cleese to tell him and then yeah
share it share it with us because
i'm saying some [ __ ] like uh like slam
those brad berries that would be
unbelievable yeah can i get him to say
that we can try we can be like what the
[ __ ] is this no he's a great guy john uh
he it's been fantastic to work with both
for payday 2 and as well as raiders i'm
going to put that on my resume
one of hitler's finest now as you can
see it's actually the game director oh
really
yeah
definitely dad yes yeah i met him when i
was in sweden you can still be useful
which reminds me the letter please yeah
because you were stringent yes
dear mr
hitler very soon you're going to be
hearing about us
a lot
therefore allow me to what this is give
you an idea of level design and stuff
precisely yeah so i mean ilya the the
great director he
has a extensive level design experience
right especially from old school games
right so uh so
it's a lot of emphasis on on the level
design and making sure it's as fun as
possible
because we're all about the gameplay
right that's our biggest focus if you
enjoy playing the game i mean just look
at payday right people have hundreds of
hours some people have thousands of
hours you know and this is the same
thing we're going for with raid world
war ii
um
we can't wait to get started
see you soon sincerely mrs white looks
super fun dude i might get into it
tonight yeah you should you definitely
should all of you should get in there
fight the war we need you on the
battlefield you should all be playing
i'm gonna i'm gonna play tonight steal
yeah fight the nazis steal some nazi
gold yeah it's the perfect uh perfect
raid action and uh heisting during the
second world war is
completely different from heisting in in
you know 2017 you know with uh in
washington dc with john wick yeah john
wick ethan and gila klein and and chains
maybe i don't know which other heister
would
want to join that mix-up cool well i
wish you guys the best of luck thank you
dude i am looking forward to that dlc
it's gonna be so much fun for people to
play as me and ela
i'm super excited it's yeah it's gonna
be uh it's gonna be a lot of fun and i
think people are going to be positively
surprised you know how how serious you
guys took it yeah no because it's so
it's so easy to say like uh these guys
are just screwing around you know but
you guys really really took it serious
and uh and it's gonna be really exciting
to see how the payday community reacts
to it there's a lot of laughs in there
too like they gave us a lot of room for
improvising lions and just [ __ ]
goofing around so we had a lot of fun
yeah it's going to meet up cool all
right cool thanks man thank you dude
thanks for stopping by thank you
appreciate you everyone god bless you
and uh
papa bless yeah thank you
let's see what's out in the peanut
gallery let's see here
stand by we've got monkey
hey monkey what up
how are you
i'm good how are you i'm good dude
what's up
um i just wanted to know um
since i know that you play guitar um i
just wanted to know have you ever
considered trying any other instruments
and uh do you have a certain instrument
that you would like to play in the
future oh wow thank you for the question
appreciate you
bro man
well i don't play guitar
i guess he's talking about like [ __ ]
mata
i used to play guitar when i was in
college i used to make
i used to goof around on the guitar a
little bit but i'm not really a serious
musician i love music but i'm not very
good at playing it
um i wish i always wish i played piano
that'd be piano is by far the coolest
instrument
let's take one more from big tuna
big tuna jake what up doggie how are you
what's going on ethan how's it going man
i'm good man how are you
i'm doing great
so i wanted to ask you um you know i've
heard you mentioned before that
you know some of your uh your creative
inspirations but i wanted to know
you know growing up did you have any you
know big role models or heroes and how
did they impact you know the decisions
you made or or just your childhood in
general
cool thanks for the question yeah have a
good one man
god i don't think i had any role models
growing up i think that's why i'm so
[ __ ] up
does everyone have role models is that
something that people have
did you have a role model dan
a role model i mean
yeah that's a i don't not really i know
some people have it but they're like i
loved this person but i don't know that
i had a role model
i just played video games all day i
didn't do [ __ ]
yeah it's like what's your role i'd have
i'd be a better person if i had a role
model i wish i had a role model
all right
no
not really
um
let's see what do we got you know i've
been exercising a lot i've been talking
a lot about like depression and [ __ ]
like that and like just being sad
and um
i don't know i've been i've been hitting
the bike lately
and that [ __ ] really works man it like
i did read a study that like people who
take antidepressants to get rid of their
anxiety or depression
that exercise is actually
statistically
the best treatment
for like depression anxiety compared to
antidepressants it's better
and it make you know it makes sense like
your physical appearance is so tied in
with um
like how you feel about yourself
if you just are like a fat
elf like i am
that [ __ ] really like gets it gets in
your head you know
but just the act of exercising too like
i'll put on tv hit the bike
i don't know just gets my mind off it's
like a good outlet of energy so i just
think everyone out there who's who's
feeling kind of
who has those feelings
i think most of us do
is that exercise is so important dude
i went like 10 years of my life without
[ __ ] doing anything
basically just like sitting at an office
come home sit at a computer
sitting at a computer for like 16 hours
a day they say that sitting
is the new smoking
that apparently like just sitting
like we do
increases your chance of death by the
way i love that phrase
they don't say what of because there's
just too many options
increases chance of death
by like 30 percent
what there's no buzz
it's not worth it
apparently well some people who exercise
say they do get a buzz no i meant from
sitting
oh man
it's smoking yeah i would rather [ __ ]
smoke that's true
yeah you don't get a buzz from smoking
though you mostly just feel like [ __ ]
although you smoked for you smoked you
know
i smoked for
10 years god damn did you get a buzz
maybe like the first time
i mean yeah you got a nicotine buzz a
little bit
get a little [ __ ] hey how you doing
yeah
mostly it's just the inverse though
where you feel like [ __ ] when you don't
have it so although you're vaping now
you your boy are you getting more you're
getting more nicotine now than you were
when you were smoking probably if you
hit that vape pretty hard i hit it a
pretty good amount but uh i used like
the lowest nicotine count so i don't
know how that equals out
ah vaping saves
and apparently and sitting kills so
that's right
i'm just saying we've talked you know i
get a lot of emails from people who are
like i'm depressed
you know
that conversation you have was really
interesting a lot of stuff like that i'm
saying man
you gotta like
you gotta take action you gotta like
take [ __ ] into your own hands because
it's so easy just to lay
lay down and feel like [ __ ] sad and
despaired just go for a walk man go for
a run
do something with that energy
did you uh play sports growing up
sports not really
not even like little league i did a
little i
i did a little little luke but i hated
it i [ __ ] hate it i didn't want to be
there i want to be at home playing
everquest
oh i [ __ ] hate it talking my language
now um
you know i played water polo a little
bit in high school i was fit boy i was
tan and i was fit damn
and fully virgin by the way
not damn on that i was a straight up but
i looked good as hell boy
so anyway i don't know i just some
thoughts ahead on that this is
exercising this morning hour on the bike
watching kill the kill by the way i know
i'm late to that game
killa kill this anime i don't know if
you guys seen this it's basically just
hentai
it's like straight up porn the show is
really good it's got this comp it's an
anime it's got this completely nutty
plotline about like different clothing
giving you super powers and [ __ ] like
that
and i i know it's like meant to be a
parody of anime in a way
but it's like
straight up porn dude
i totally under like i didn't really
understand hentai but now that i see
that like kids grew up watching this
[ __ ] like if i was 13 watching this [ __ ]
whoo
all we had was sailor moon
that [ __ ] was was that hot i haven't
watched sailor moon well
it's it's not like what dan what the
kids are rocking these dan dan's jerks
[ __ ]
many times to sailor moon by the sound
of it oh yeah
back in the day when like um
[ __ ] were desperate back then boy no
internet you would like
there'd be like a commercial where like
one girl has like a little more cleavage
than normal and you're like oh [ __ ]
i'm waiting for that commercial to come
on you don't care about this show you're
just like dude
[ __ ] was rough back then but
get a catalog of like
victorious secrets
in the mailbox
don't know i'm spoiled i'm telling you
man i remember when i was in when i got
dial-up i was one of the first people to
dial up internet i would sit i know this
is a joke but i swear to god you would
sit you would go to like boobs.com
because you were like 12.
and then you would pull up a picture and
literally it would take like five
minutes to load my line yeah so it'd be
like you'd see her face you're like
she's cute
then you get to the cleavage you don't
even know if she's naked
you have to wait you know she's a she
yeah that's that's that's a new problem
i feel like
that's a whole nother issue that kids
are dealing with these days the world is
changing um
anyway i just i am
she seems like people are depressed so
much these days
you know
i was talking to my friend good friend
of mine
and he
is very successful in what he what he
chose to do
and we were just like dude why like
it's just like what the [ __ ] like why
aren't we like happy all the time like
why is there always like some kind of
like void right
it's weird it's like there's never
there's never a place where you're like
dope i made it it's all good forever
i don't know one of my theories is that
like
by the way i'm not like super depressed
or anything i'll just say that it's just
something to think about it's kind of
interesting it's like i've i've achieved
beyond my wildest dreams four years ago
like this is all i could ever dream of
and all everything i ever pursued
was like always something else but it's
just like everything we do is so
unnatural it feels like you know
like real [ __ ] like real human biology
is to like
[ __ ] pick
pick cucumbers from your garden and
[ __ ] feed your kids and [ __ ]
like build a house or some [ __ ]
but like we like i'm just saying like
that's real [ __ ] like that's that's the
problem that's like what we're geared to
be like satisfied by yeah
all of our lives are so unnatural like
i'm some [ __ ] who sits in his room
and films itself and puts it on the
internet like that's just it's a weird
thing to do
got to build a house something and we'll
never do it pick a cucumber
you know that's all it really takes you
pick cucumbers
no that's pickable
yeah yeah you could pick a cucumber okay
all right
so anyway it's just a whole [ __ ]
thing i've got a bunch of videos here i
want to watch this [ __ ] was this [ __ ]
was mad
macy gray you guys remember this lady
you may see gray
what was that hit song she had
she's trying to
say goodbye but she chokes
so anyway she put on this performance
and some of the footage came out it was
just like damn
yikes
[Music]
apparently she came on like eight hours
late
[Music]
drunk as [ __ ]
can you imagine paying for that
i feel bad for her though
i feel bad for everybody there this
dude's just screaming boring how about
twitch chat in real life yeah
yikes
she was hot [ __ ] for a minute i don't
know i didn't realize that she
she fell off so hard
she was she was huge for a minute when i
was i don't know when was that like the
2000s yeah early 2000s wasn't she was
kind of one hit though right
i only really think that one song
it was fun i used to always joke with
post malone
about he was like i'm just a one hit
wonder when he just had white iverson
and then he had like congratulations
like i'm just a two-hit wonder
now he's killing it dude i know if you
guys have checked out his new single
rock star
it's killing he broke
the itunes streaming record for the
first 24 hours
our boy posty isn't that insane
super happy for him be jake paul even
yeah well yeah
if jake paul dropped his at the same
time he austin wouldn't have a chance in
hell
he got lucky on the timing
um
but it's number one across the board i i
don't think i can play it because i'll
get like copyright strike by the whole
freaking
the whole music industry but check out
post's new single rock star
proud of his ass i'm like dude that's
three hits
that's legit so you're pretty much just
a musician now yeah you're pretty much
just a musician at this point
um
god
i went down this whole rabbit hole here
of
of um
i saw this thing on reddit
and as someone who who used to be a
server for two years it was absolutely
horrifying
this server is walking with um
hotpot you guys know what that is it's
like super hot [ __ ] it's like some
japanese thing i think or chinese i
don't know
where they just
mega boil all this [ __ ] in a pot and
then bring it to the table
god these restaurant accidents freak me
the [ __ ] out it's like so senseless and
random and and it's like nobody's fault
really i mean
[ __ ] like here watch this
like
ugh
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude just slips all went
dude just slips and just [ __ ] whoa
that's disturbing it's yeah i think this
happened in china
but it's like what can you do what are
you how do you apparently so i was
reading like generally speaking it's a
good idea to put your kid on the inside
i do i would never even think about that
i guess as a parent you learn about all
this [ __ ] i don't even keep playing that
for you guys
but it's like what the [ __ ]
can you do sometimes life just comes at
you and drops a hot pot of [ __ ]
boiling
oil in your face jesus christ you know
um
reminding me i'm just god serving is the
worst job in the world but it's not that
bad because you me me and dan were
talking about the other day it's kind of
the worst job but not that bad
but like [ __ ] like this can happen
you're just some guy working a deadbeat
job and all of a sudden you like
ruined some kid's life
i had to uh heimlich somebody once at my
table really yeah he was straight up
choking did you save his life
i mean did you get it out i guess yeah
we got it did he tip you nice
no
he didn't actually what a monster yeah
no piece of
[ __ ] what you should she shove that
[ __ ] tortilla chip back down his
throat
[ __ ] how the [ __ ] you're not
gonna leave twenty percent when someone
heimlicks you you're like dude this is
this is not my job description it was
like
yeah
it's pathetic
did you say anything
oh no have you ever said anything about
a bad tip
no never did that i mean not to their
faces
some people do that it's a bold move
yeah i mean i had all these like dreams
that you know in my last week i was
gonna just blow up in people's faces but
you know what
you just move on yeah
it's better to move on in cases like
that
but anyway you've got um
i just went down this rabbit hole of all
this spill [ __ ] and
it happened to me once where i was
serving
a family
and i had like a tray of beer of like
pints of beers and tall glasses and i
was leaning over serving them and i and
i spilled an entire pint of beer on a
little kid's over his head
and they were pissed and it was super
like it was awful
imagine if it was like boiling water
watch this psa this [ __ ] is it does not
[ __ ] around
here apparently this is some work safety
accident psa in canada
i've got this amazing fiance
who i won't be marrying this weekend
because i'm about to be in a terrible
accident
but really i should have cleaned up the
grease over there and they should never
put the deep fryer so cool
so much comical
wait what it gets better
prevent it
guys these do not [ __ ] around living
[ __ ] was that yeah they really
they really get you with that huh
it's you have to laugh it's just so
absurd but it's powerful it's like just
put down a mat
yeah against the point across it
definitely gets the point across the
fact they showed her like skin boiling
off yeah they didn't shy away from that
i love the whole i was gonna get married
but now i'm a monster
that guy like ducks down like he's under
fire in a war zone
hits the deck
there's um there's so much
um
here's another one oh god
wait am i pulling that up holy [ __ ]
that's the wrong one
look at this [ __ ] look at this dumb ass
[ __ ] dude is pouring hot grease into a
bucket in the middle of the [ __ ]
walkway and this poor girl slips on the
grease look at he's like smiling
whoops
oh my god mcdonald's we're dreams where
dreams come true
i'll take one happy meal without
third degree burn
you gotta be safe out there guys
seriously
now you guys remember the mcdonald's
coffee thing i found this really really
interesting okay this is kind of a
shocking image so i'm just gonna warn
you now but i remember you guys all
probably remember the mcdonald's lawsuit
when the lady spilled the hot coffee on
her thighs
and
everyone was goofing on her like oh this
is a
frivolous lawsuit i can't believe this
woman is getting millions of dollars she
spilled coffee everyone knows coffee is
hot right
you remember that [ __ ] dan
yeah yeah it was a
huge deal at the time so everyone's
clowning on this lady
meanwhile
this is actually i'm warning you now
this shit's [ __ ] up
this is the this is what happened to her
people don't actually realize that they
[ __ ] this poor lady up
like third degree burns all on her
crotch like she got destroyed the worst
and the worst part is everyone in the
media is like oh this frivolous lawsuit
like [ __ ] this lady
lie back versus mcdonald's also known as
mcdonald's coffee case
was a 1999 product liability lawsuit
that became a flash point in the debate
in the united states over tort reform
she was awarded 3 million dollars to a
79 year old woman who suffered 30 degree
burns in her pelvic region
apparently she only won after some
back and forth 640 000. she was
hospitalized for eight days while she
underwent skin grafting and required two
years of medical treatment
is that sure it costs
more than three million to be honest
i think it said so about medical care
yeah i think it said it costs like a
million dollars actually in the medical
care
but like um
yeah i just i when i actually looked
into that because i remember my parents
talking about that and everyone making
fun of this lady
when i actually saw the details of this
i was like holy [ __ ] this is completely
legitimate
abc news called it the poster child of
excessive lawsuit
but
you know what i mean i i gotta tip the
beanie to that lady she raised a lot of
awareness about work space
workspace awareness and stuff
i mean that hot coffee should probably
save a lot of uh
save some lives
possibly
anyway
uh i want to give a quick shout out
at the top of the show here
bottom of the show here
you guys know this guy
this guy who makes all these awesome
remixes in our at the beginning of the
show and for our music this guy cool
songs i want to give a shout out to this
guy man he makes the best [ __ ]
music
[Music]
[Music]
but like what what's he made famously
made like ethan trapberry he's made like
all these amazing songs he was here yeah
i think we got like
five of his songs on the playlist
so people always asking like um
they want to buy this song they want to
know where can they buy the song get
like a playlist or some [ __ ]
so anyway i just i said hey put together
an album for the people so if you guys
want to support cool songs
there's a link in the description you
can buy a it's a 10-track album with
three bonus tracks with all your
favorite spoofs and goofs and laughs
and it's available
in the link in the description if you
want to support this cool dude cool
songs
and um here i'll
i'll put in yeah i'll put it in the chat
too here let me spam it there
anyway
shout out to that guy he deserves some
love man he's been grinding for us for
he's been grinding forever for us doing
cool ass [ __ ] and not getting much love
so god bless him out there
his editing is uh on point too it's
hilarious they're always great you know
i was talking to him he's like the songs
i cook up immediately the editing is
what takes him forever yeah his his
clips are awesome
he's got stevo thickness humongous and
of course everyone's favorite anal
so anyway yeah i i've seen enough people
asking that i thought it'd be cool all
the all the proceeds go to him by the
way
so anyway i'm gonna keep it brief today
ela is back tomorrow thank god
somebody needs to change my diapee
i'm sick of doing that man
i'm done he doesn't get paid enough for
this [ __ ] literally
and um
yeah this friday
tune in it's gonna be a great episode i
have so many questions for these guys
i'm i'm legitimately excited who's the
guest who's the guys uh that'd be this
ethan sometimes sometimes
i'm ethan bradberry and mo
and and and
like six font
here's this little short brief little
hey how you doing
um
it's gonna be good i'm i'm i'm dying out
here solo
i need to side i need a side
lady this is rough i'm tumbling out here
like a [ __ ] tumbleweed from the wild
west
sad lonely try
what's up
got you on the wide
oh yeah just i mean look on the wide
shot if you don't believe me look at
this a huge empty room
so anyway that's me holding it down solo
i hope that you know it was all right
for you
it's my last one
anyway thank everyone for watching thank
you for letting us be a part of your
tuesday god bless you papa bless you
thank you to everyone who subscribed on
twitch
thank you to our sponsors
and um looking forward to seeing you
guys on friday super super jacked so
until then
papa bless appreciate you
bye